[Music]
[Applause]
the flag may just smothers it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
amazing isn't it how he can just be
taken in real fake scripted or animated
lightsaber duels aerials showdowns or
gun-slinging standoffs fighting is
something that has held the interest of
mankind for thousands of years the
oldest sport in the world is wrestling
the current highest-paid athlete is a
boxer the cinematic dynasty that
dominates the box-office today is
centered around fighting but why our
fight scenes so captivating what is it
about them that holds our attention so
perfectly in this video I hope to
outline what I believe are the most
important aspects to create a compelling
fight scene and what better fight to
focus this video on then the fight that
started it all for me when I was 9 years
old the same fight that made my interest
blossom into a passion and eventually an
obsession today we are taking an
in-depth look at what I call Akira
Toriyama's fight scene masterpiece Goku
vs. Ajit
[Music]
if you were to ask fans of action films
what they thought the most important
part of a fight scene was most would be
inclined to answer with quite simply the
action it is an action scene after all
just show some spectacular stunts and
feats of strength that should suffice
correct well no actually for one simple
reason a good fight scene needs context
the setup is important and something
that I think quite elegantly
demonstrates this fact is the sport of
boxing typically speaking in a boxing
pay-per-view the entire show is sold on
its main event exclusively the Floyd
Mayweather vs Conor McGregor fight was
what every one shoe did to seed in 2017
I'm certain many of you watching this
video right now saw the fight but how
many of you were excited for or even
watched any of the other seven fights
that night I would imagine the number is
drastically lower than the number of
pay-per-view buys the show ended up
receiving and that is because with those
fights there were no established stakes
their characters were not defined and
the viewers didn't know anything about
them I have no doubt the individuals
involved in those fights were
exceptional athletes but that usually
isn't enough to capture attention what
they needed and this is the same thing
any good writer of a bite scene is
looking for is to give the viewers or
readers why when writing Dragonball
Akira Toriyama made absolutely certain
before Goku and Vegeta even laid eyes on
each other the following questions had
been answered for his readers what is at
stake well thanks to Raddatz we learned
that the impending Saiyans Vegeta and
nappa are a group that wipe out entire
civilizations and cell planets as well
as that when they do arrive a number of
the Earth's defenders were killed
therefore if the fight doesn't end in
Goku's favor then he loses
and everyone what has their journey been
like to get to where he is today Goku
has sacrificed himself in defense of the
earth he has travelled across the
heavens and sought the teachings of a
new more powerful master to meet the
impending challenges and finally what
are their motivations Goku is motivated
by a desire to challenge himself against
someone like Vegeta to revive his fallen
comrades is also at the forefront of his
mind to achieve this he needs to defeat
Vegeta Vegeta on the other hand is
motivated by a desire to gather the
Dragon Balls to make his wish for
immortality and to rule the universe to
achieve this he needs to defeat Goku
[Applause]
it's no secret that trash-talking sells
Steve Austin made a career out of it the
rock did too and even Floyd and Connor
have utilized this in their respective
careers trash-talking is used to
antagonize your opponent but it also
adds some much-needed personality and
charisma to the equation a fight becomes
very boring without an understanding of
the personalities involved and an
effective way of establishing
personality is through dialogue the WWE
and other wrestling organizations see
the value of establishing characters for
this very reason you will not see a
single wrestling show without something
that is called
a promo a promo is a monologue or a
chance for a performer to communicate
directly to the audience or to call
someone out this is a fantastic way of
communicating character and to help the
audience find out what it is you stand
for every character needs this before
and I will fight you on this the most
iconic standoff in animation history
Vegeta gives Goku an ultimatum a be his
right-hand man and together they can
overthrow the cosmos or be to defy him
if this had been the first time we saw
anything to do with Dragon Ball this
scene alone would effectively
communicate Vegeta and Goku
personalities to the audience perfectly
Vegeta the Saiyan Prince with a fighting
potential in a
for elite class fighting for selfish
reasons Goku the lower-class
outcasts fighting for the fate of his
home however what shows personality more
than what you say is how you react and
what you do and accurate Auriemma knew
this when he wrote Dragonball the
Kamehameha versus Gallic gun beam
struggle is one of if not my absolute
favorite set peace in all of the series
it's vitally important that your
characters physically communicate their
personalities and traits to the audience
and no other set peace more emphatically
communicates this than the beam struggle
because of who Goku is he has gained the
abilities and necessary to close the gap
that existed between himself and Vegeta
Vegeta because of who he is decides that
since he can't compete with Goku
hand-to-hand he decides to take the
easier option which is to threaten the
planet so as to bait Goku into taking
the full brunt of his attack preying on
his value system from this very instance
we learn a host of new things about
Vegeta in this moment he's desperate
he's resourceful and his ruthless as the
tension rises and the threat has been
issued Vegeta Jets into the air Goku
reacts as an imposing presence looming
above Vegeta begins to charge his attack
without second-guessing himself
Goku plants his feet and throws caution
to the wind igniting the kaio-ken
technique putting his body at extreme
risk and in harm's way once again during
this scene there's a beautiful amount of
visual storytelling taking place also
Goku is quite literally and figuratively
the only thing standing between the
earth and its destruction positioning
Vegeta above Goku like this also
communicates to the viewer or reader
that Vegeta is again superior to Goku
this method was also implemented during
their standoff Vegeta standing above
Goku mirroring his vision of himself
atop the hierarchy
the following point I want to make here
actually was the inspiration for this
video it's a point I don't hear brought
up at all and is something I believe is
nowadays the most important aspect to
keeping a fight scene compelling what I
am talking about is the pacing of a
fight scene if I was asked to pinpoint
the moment the fight began between Goku
and Vegeta I would say right here and
again if I was asked when the fight
ended I would have to say here but
what's in the middle the fight right
well yes and no if I wanted to between
the beginning and the ending I pointed
out I could outline 13 individual
stories that are being told over the
course of this entire fight this is how
the author of a comic or story manages
the attention span of his or her viewers
there are most definitely more than 13
individual stories that take place
during this section this just happens to
be what I came up with off the top of my
head but the point I am trying to make
with this time table is that there is
more to a single fight than just what
you think you are seeing making up this
single fight is a series of
interconnected stories pay attention to
this the next time you see a fight scene
and see if you can identify when the
subject of the fight itself changes
either momentarily or completely this
constant shift in focus helps keep the
viewers attention too strong throughout
what I am about to break down for you is
common knowledge to most hardcore pro
wrestling fans but perhaps even they
might not see the correlation between
that and every fight scene in most
stories and of course this pertains
exclusively to fiction
okay so let's break it down in order to
effectively pace a long fight scene you
need to make sure you do at least some
of these things during it these things
are the shine the cut off the hope the
double down and the finish no I can hear
you already what are they and where do
they apply to the Goku and Vegeta fight
well I'm glad you asked the shine this
is where the good guy in this case Goku
demonstrates his superior ability to the
bad guy who is in this case Vegeta the
shine is when we see how the fight would
go if it was done
100% fairly this gives the audience an
idea of what the good guy is capable of
so the shine in this instance was the
opening to the fight
Goku's initial Florrie and his kaio-ken
times three akira toriyama uses this to
communicate who is the superior fighter
and just as things are going well we are
thrusted into the next phase the cutoff
the cutoff is when the bad guy decides
that enough is enough things are not
going his way and so it's time to use
the various means to gain the upper hand
over the good gun this is when vegeta
decides to threaten the earth in an
attempt at gaining the upper hand on
goku eventually resorting to
transforming into the Oh Zahraa
transformation which multiplies his
strength ten times over the fight is now
dominated by Vegeta and during the bad
guys domination we get introduced to the
third phase the hope this is the moment
or moments during a fight where through
clever planning skill or tenacity the
good guy manages to turn fortune in his
favor before being brought to his knees
again by the bad guy this is to create
the illusion to the viewer or reader
that the good guy still has a chance of
gaining the upper hand before taking it
away again there are a number of moments
in this fight that matched this
description it could be Goku's initial
solar flare and charging of the spirit
bomb it could be when the a gob cuts off
the Gena's tail but what sticks down
more than anything to me in my head was
this the spirit bomb connects with
Vegeta causing him to fly miles into the
air only to crash to the earth once
again however despite taking a lofty
amount of damage from the blast Vegeta
still rise himself enough to remain in a
dominant position the double death the
Double Down his win all fighters
involved are incapacitated on their
backs unable to move with exhaustion the
playing field has been leveled this
usually manifests due to his
split-second decision made by the good
guy or a mistake made by the bad guy
this is when Gohan falls onto the GIDA
as the Azzaro
Vegeta up until this point had been
systematically dismantling the Earth's
defenses overcoming every trap but with
the help of Goku and a miscalculation on
Vegeta sparked which he defines himself
crushed beneath an enormous loser who go
Han resulting in himself Gohan
Krillin and Goku all
down for the count until finally the
finish this is as the name suggests when
the conclusion to the fight takes place
and it just so happens to segue nicely
into the final part of this video I love
this section and I think accurate or
yama has a wonderful flair for the
dramatic - when you are writing your
conclusion you ideally want to write it
in such a way that it's not immediately
predictable to the reader or viewer this
means that when you were faced with
writing an ending to your face do not
choose the first thing that comes to
your mind don't even pick the first five
things
choose the sixth option at least chances
are it will surprise your viewer that
way there are a lot of instances that
caught me off-guard when I first watched
this as a kid it was Vegeta's decision
to fire the blaster at the earth yani
Robi's tail slice Gohan's
o's are ants formation and finally
Vegeta's escape at the hands of crewmen
and once your ending is established the
important thing is to invite further
storytelling and this is achieved
through planting seeds for the next arc
in the middle of the current one to be
called back on at the end in this case
it was their decision to pursue Nemec as
you can probably tell I could gosh and
talk about this topic for hours fight
scenes are a magnificent means of
telling a story while appealing to our
instincts as human beings and Goku's
first clash with the jito has and always
will hold a special place as my
introduction to the world of Dragon Ball
so if you thought that all a fight scene
was was action and nothing more I hope
now you can appreciate the careful
planning and strategy that goes into
mapping out something as complex as this
and more than your typical fight scene
these physical demonstrations are
incredibly effective vehicles in telling
entertaining and compelling narratives
full of catharsis surprise and character
or put quite simply this classic Dragon
Ball masterclass reminds us all that
there is more than we think going on
behind the scenes when it comes to
perfecting a fight scene thank you so
much for watching
[Music]
you